à l'occasion des 150 ans de la société
des missionnaires d'afrique les pères
blancs et des soeurs missionnaires notre
dame d'afrique les soeurs blanches je
reçois le père gilles barrette et la
soeur et à tous tant merci beaucoup
d'être venu en studio alors d'abord je
pense à vous
soeur rita qui sont les soeurs blanches
au juste alors là sur blanche ont été
fondés âgées en 1969 18-10 1969 c'est la
refondation
après ça s 50 ans après y avait comme
une revitalisation de la congrégation
suite aux évènements et du changement
des évolutions du charisme alors nous
avons été fondée à âgées par le cardinal
lavigerie et très tôt il a senti le
besoin d'avoir des collaboratrices
féminine à ce moment là parce qu'avais
une famine qui sévit sait et il voyait
que le travail auprès des enfants auprès
des femmes pouvaient mieux se faire par
des religieuses et en même temps en
france en bretagne il y avait une jeune
fille de 20 ans marie-renée au dos qui
plus tard ont donné comme sur le nom de
serna les [ __ ] mais qui sont un appel
à la vocation religieuse et elle a
répondu aussitôt à l'appel du cardinal
lavigerie pour avoir des personnes pour
venir à alger
elle ne savait pas tellement comment ça
allait se passer mais elle est venue
vraiment avec toute cette générosité et
sa confiance
elle suivait sa vocation perdre père
tout en s que vous aussi les pères
blancs ont été créés en même temps
qu'eux
les soeurs blanches quelques mois
auparavant ok en fait la vigerie venait
d'être nommé évêque à alger et à cause
de cette épidémie qui sévit avec aux
maladies que cela entraînait il a fait
appel à la communauté catholique sur
place il ya eu très peu de réponses
d'autant plus que le gouverneur français
la vérité à ce moment là le département
français il ya eu très peu de réponses
voyant se rédimer le moi je faire appel
à un personnel extérieur pour que ces
besoins humains soient pris en compte
dans le travail quotidien et c'est comme
ça qu'il a lancé un appel pour que les
pères et frères blanc sont fondés et eu
des réponses assez rapidement et
quelques mois plus tard c'était des
soeurs blanches qui est le but premier
était d'être présent à ce monde musulman
puisque le gouverneur il lui disait à ce
casse cet évêque occupez-vous de 4x ne
vous n'allez pas de la question des
musulmans or le fondateur a dit au moins
vous ne pourrez pas de m'empêcher de me
les musulmans comme un père aime ses
enfants
on traitera la maladie la famine etc a
fait que petit à petit et les pères et
les frères et les soeurs se sont
déployées d'abord en algérie puis ont
traversé en tunisie avant que plusieurs
années plus tard ayant obtenu la vigerie
la permission de penser au continent
africain en général
il y envoie pertes en vies humaines
épatant à travers les chemins ouverts
par les explorateurs envoyés en afrique
noire danseurs tout en vous êtes
toujours lié les soeurs blanches dit si
vous êtes toujours lié à oasis à
l'origine française de deux de
l'organisation ou bien vous êtes
complètement autonome comme sert blanche
d'afrique mais étant installé au canada
merci c'est une bonne question depuis le
début c'est vrai que nous avons été
fondée par est un casino français est
une personne qui a été très
significative qui a été plus tard
l'expérience générale pour presque une
cinquantaine d'années mais dès les
débuts vivent en communauté
interculturel
alors le leadership et partager ça
dépend de qui était dû au conseil
général et notre maison généralice est à
rome depuis 1964 un moment donné ça a
été on a vu que c'était mieux de rome
[Musique]
notre administration centrale
alors nous sommes nous vivons vraiment
un communauté internationale et berbère
barrette vous êtes qu ensemble dans tous
les pays où ils allaient les pères
blancs et aussi les soeurs blanches
à l'origine c'était ont marché main dans
la main l'idée était que les religieuses
pouvant plus facilement rencontrer les
femmes et les enfants et offrir des
services
les pères et des frères davantage
rencontrer les hommes en pays musulmans
les hommes ne peuvent pas rencontré les
musulmanes valaisan est de même pour les
religieuses alors l'idée était que les
rencontres et les femmes et les enfants
les faire rencontrer les enfants les
jeunes garçons les étudiants et puis
parce qu'il y avait des étudiants ce
moment là et les adultes homme cynique
dans les partages entre les communautés
les soeurs et les pères nous informions
de ce que les uns et les roses avaient
senti comme mentalité comme
problématique et une cherchons ensemble
qui religieuse qui père ou frère allait
lancer un centre technique par exemple
alors c'était parce que il y avait une
collaboration de nous visite dans les
villages de secours au début on n'était
que des visiteurs de village en rang des
dix heures de bonjour à gauche à droite
alors en apprenant la langue
petit à petit on a appris à échanger
entre nous soeur et bear ou civils qu on
pouvait miser sur la vie familiale vous
pouvez miser sur l'évolution et de la
femme et des enfants et des hommes et
penser un futur pour les enfants on a
toujours on a toujours évité même si ce
n'a pas été le cas pour chaque personne
de parler de missionnaires part c'est un
mot qui n'est pas bien reçue au monde
musulman nous on préfère actuellement
parler de pousser à fond là
l'humanisation total des hommes et des
femmes est notre référence c'est jésus
christ d'accord ça tout le temps est ce
que toutes les soeurs blanches
s'invectivent mans blanche ou bien vous
avez intégré aussi quelques soeur l'eau
calme qui ne sont pas nécessairement
blanche la question en effet de haut
débit nous étions des soeurs blanches
mais de plusieurs pays d'europe canada
etats unis et plus tard et nous avons pu
accueillir des serres africaine mais
avant ça c'était l'idée aussi avec les
missionnaires d'afrique d'établir
l'église ce qu'on appelle l'église
locale qu'il y à du personnel sur place
et nous avons accompagné la formation de
22 congrégation des soeurs africaine
diocésaine est maintenant quelques
intentions de ce qu'on appelle de relier
à rome directement de droit pontifical
est elle-même maintenant
soumissionnaires à leur tour dans leur
pays dans les pays environnants et même
dans d'autres continents et nous pouvons
en voir plusieurs qui sont ici à
montréal pour des formations et dans
d'autres pays vernant pour un service
aussi dans la société et moi même je vis
avec une compagne qui vient du burundi
et lætitia mission au québec
ben gibbard est bon il ya plusieurs
prêtres
plusieurs frères en afrique il ya
plusieurs congrès congrégration je pense
par exemple aux frères ou soeurs du
sacré coeur qu'est ce qui vous distingue
de co2 congrégation la faute de demander
aux autres on sait combien sous voie
avec nous et il nous semble nous que on
a été parmi les premiers sinon les
premiers dans plusieurs pays à mettre en
premier lieu la question d'apprendre la
langue parlée par les gens donc notre
fondateur disait au bout de six mois il
faut que les trois ou quatre confrères
d'une communauté peut importer
nationalité d'origine échanges dans la
langue locale africaine mans
alors tous les perdants toutes les
soeurs blanches on a appris une deux
trois quatre langues africaines selon
les les années les nominations qui nous
ont été proposés on a misé sur la langue
française et la langue anglaise en
premier pour tout le monde parce que à
ce moment là les colonies là où nous
étions missionnaire il y avait sept et
les pays ex autrefois colonisées par
l'angleterre ou car la france est
exactement où le ou la belgique
alors ces deux langues anglais et
français ont été les langues
obligatoires pour tous le perdre et les
soeurs blanches en plus des langues
africaines ce qui nous distingue encore
c'est la proche
on ne commence pas nécessairement par
une école primaire
on commence par la relation avec le chef
du village les autorités du village où
les autos étaient de l'ethnie opéra pour
faciliter l'acceptation aussi pour que
la wii pour que nous soyons accueilli
pour que le cher 10 bienvenue ou même si
ce il ne peut pas ne pas se poser la
question qui sont ces personnes
qu'est-ce que ce que ça veut dire leur
présence alors on a commencé par nous et
sur qui sont les personnes qui ont une
influence sur la majorité des autres les
chefs par exemple dans les relations ont
été faites ch avec les chefs et petit à
petit on ne peut aller visiter les
malades les femmes enceintes les pensées
à creuser des puits penser à ma
une école primaire où l'on plus tard des
écoles techniques et assez vite
elles ne seraient pas en parler penser
en termes de l'église locale qui n'était
pas encore là il fallait viser le jour
où les africains seraient autonomes dans
leur propre pays et dans leur propre
église et nous étant des serviteurs donc
miser sur une formation de compétences
ou à offrir aux africaines ou africaines
ça je crois que ça nous distingue dans
la méthode de commencement de présence
alors ça c'est des secteurs très
importants que le père barret tu évoques
s'arrêta donc ça signifie que vous êtes
vraiment dans des domaines bien
spécifiques
on a parlé de la maladie l'éducation
c'est ce sont les principaux secteurs
dans lesquels vous aviez otoshi je
dirais que depuis toujours nous avons
répondu aux besoins sur place et salue
la vision de devoir au début comme on
disait il n'y avait pas d'école
c'était comme ça un peu partout dans le
monde les écoles alors pour pour nous
les hommes on allait visiter les gens
pour les encourager à venir
avoir des ateliers de compétences d'où
la fiabilisation apprendre des choses
pour la santé et surtout encourager des
petites filles de venir aussi participé
recevoir une formation c'était les
choses du début et puis avec les besoins
grandissants et toujours en
collaboration avec les gouvernements sur
place soit les gouvernements avant les
indépendances et après les indépendances
avec un lien avec les nations unies
allaient les programmes de santé
nous avons participé beaucoup de
l'éducation par les écoles à tous les
niveaux et aussi
des dispensaires des hôpitaux des
centres communautaires
là on pouvait aller surtout dans les
milieux ruraux
parce que dans les villes c'était plus
facile d'avoir des services et dans d un
parti à vannes
c'était très difficile pour les
professionnels se classent d'aller se
déplacer à cause des des besoins
d'éducation de leurs familles alors par
exemple en tanzanie au cours des années
avait peut-être 45% des services de
santé était rendu ils ont par l'église
mais surtout dans les endroits rivaux
comme c'était dans d'autres pays aussi
pas juste laissé relance mais en
collaboration avec les autres et
congrégations aussi en et femmes
je voudrais si vous permettez lui deux
exemples précis de réaliser deux
[Musique]
d'activité lesquels ou bien les pères ou
bien les y ont été engagés au burkina
faso il y avait face qu'à ce moment-là
ça s'appelait la haute volta où il nous
saoulent en français il y avait le
problème des moustiques dans les eaux
dans les lattes rivière qui affecté qui
piquent et les gens et ça faisait le des
maladies aux yeux il fallait donc
éradiquer ces les choses que j'ai trouvé
de deux de ces maladies donc la
recherche a été faite des soeurs
blanches ont collaboré des personnes
locales ont collaboré on avait un père
qui était médecin de formation qui ont
appuyé le docteur lumière la paire que
boire dix ans et il a mis sur pied tout
un programme d'éradication de
et de formation d'un personnel pour
éradiquer et guérir les personnes
si bien que les soeurs blanches mais
aussi des soeurs africaine suite aux
soeurs blanches ont été formés comme
infirmière spécialiste des yeux c'est un
exemple plus tard le même pays parce que
j'étais là pour beaucoup burkina faso il
y avait problème des femmes appelées
sorcières quand les chassés de leurs
villages
parce que on mettait sur leur dos
c'était à cause d'elle que telle femme
ne veut pas l'enfant à cause d'elle que
les enfants mouraient rebasage etc et on
les chasse est du village
les soeurs blanches ont lancé un centre
dans la capitale ouagadougou d'accueil
des sorcières ou et petit à petit
beaucoup de personnes aient entendu
parler de l'existence d'un tel centre
ont envoyé leurs vieilles mamans ou les
personnes appelées entre guillemets
social à ce centre jusqu'à ce que cela
devienne une des responsabilités du
gouvernement d'un ministère de la santé
pour les femmes donc on a transmis aux
mines au gouvernement cette oeuvre
maintenant en tout cas ça c'est quelque
chose dont vous devez être fiers comme
comme comme société est-ce que c'est des
choses comme ça de votre côté dont vous
êtes particulièrement fier comme
beaucoup coûté dessert une égalisation
spécifiques
je dirais que dans le passé elles ont
fait tellement de choses que c'est du
ces de massenet spécifique parce que
dans chaque pays
elles ont été des initiatrices de pour
les services de santé d'éducation mais
je dirais que maintenant parce que j'ai
dit qu'eads depuis on peut dire depuis
2010 est nous sommes dans une autre
phase de notre existence de notre
charisme nous travaillons beaucoup à un
réseautage
et pour ma part je suis tellement
heureuse d'être ici au canada
vim mon âge j'ai aussi passé 40 en
afrique c'est d'être capable de de
promouvoir les causes pour la justice
parce que on sait bien que c'est bien
qu'il y a des mines par exemple un peu
partout a touché est le canada est et le
centre des compagnies minières
voilà ici j'ai par exemple la chance
d'être en cohésion avec d'autres pour
promouvoir les meilleures pratiques pour
que les populations en bénéficient et
pour qu'il y ait des pratiques qui
respecte la santé et la planète alors
c'est une autre façon d'être
missionnaire dans ces stages de ma vie
et d'autre et par exemple ça pourrait
été le travail pour promouvoir le
contrôle des armes et les aider père et
nous nous sommes très actifs ici et là
pour ça pour veiller au contrôle des
angles la vente des armes dans les pays
qui cause beaucoup de conseils et aussi
ce qui se passe maintenant c'est un peu
partout dans les endroits où nous sommes
c'est l'accueil des migrants des
réfugiés et la douceur qui sont des deux
côtés des frontières pour encourager les
gens de ne pas de ne pas partir parce
que ça va être tellement dur et
difficile mais les gens et surtout les
jeunes veulent une vie meilleure rêve
d'une vie meilleure en europe
alors ils sont là d'un côté pour eux un
peu d informer les soutenir ils
participent aux mêmes dans les paroisses
dans les centres communautaires dans
l'est à tunis au maghreb en tout cas et
puis quand ils ont réussi à traverser de
l'autre côté vallée à d'autres problèmes
et puis certains dénoncent heures sont
très engagées avec d'autres pour les
recevoir pour les soutenir
pour aider à l'intégration et comme ça
se passe aux etats unis
ici aussi la l'intégration des migrants
est très important et nous reconnaissons
que dans notre pays que la part que ces
gens qui viennent comme migrants peuvent
apporter un autre pays tout à fait ils
sont des gens très bien formés et
peuvent déjà redonné beaucoup à notre
société et nous avons besoin de mesures
si vous êtes vous-même rien d'africain
du cameroun où ça nous ça nous rend nous
fait plaisir de rock dans notre propre
pays d'origine
les africains peuvent avoir un travail
peuvent exprimer leurs idées peuvent
offrir un service à la population sas
ça fait bondir donc et est justement
vous les pères blancs vous travaillez
aussi beaucoup à l'intégration des
africains et qui sont ici parce que vous
traversez pas juste de l'autre côté en
afrique mais ça serait beaucoup ici
aussi on a il ya plus de 25 ans
maintenant m 30 ans honda lancée à
montréal le centre afrika j'en ai été le
directeur pendant sept ou huit ans
l'accueil de tous les africains
quel qu'il soit il arrive et on on est
surtout des là pour écouter les quels
sont les besoins que ces africains
petit à petit vont exprimer je cherche
un logement plus grand parce qu'on m'a
mis seulement avec ma avec ma fille dans
un petit studio
maintenant ma femme va évêques les deux
jours en fonction le 16 mai au pays
il faut changer donc des demandes
ponctuelles besoin de travail
on ne cherche pas pour le logement ne
cherche pas pour eux le travail on leur
donne des pistes
débrouillez vous avec le métro avec les
moyens du bord pour aller rencontrer tel
organisme à telle adresse et l métro etc
pour que eux même plaisir j'ai fait la
démarche
on ne l'a pas fait pour moi et ils en
sont fiers or ça fait 30 ans que ce
centre existe il a des hauts et des bas
mais on découvre très souvent chez les
personnes qui arrivent au pays à
montréal je parle de morale des talents
que les personnes avaient comme enfui
parce qu'elles sont devenus médecins
vous l'avez sous on retrouve des
chauffeurs de taxi par exemple et qui
dans son pays était médecin mais les
diplômes reconnus ici ne sont pas les
mêmes en se sont reconnus dans le pays
d'origine des exigences académiques ne
sont pas les mêmes alors on les
encourage mais moyennant même si des
petits boulots au début il ya une fierté
d'avoir pu travailler gagner leur propre
argent pour subvenir à leurs propres
besoins nous nous encourageons ceux là
on peut découvrir parmi eux des des
tambourinaires ou un balafon nist
quelqu'un qui a des talents nouveaux
musicalo qui chantent
bon on encourage à se lancer de petit à
petit dans ses pistes là pour chanter ce
qu'il a envie de chanter pour jouer ce
qu'il a envie de jouer et de se faire
déjà un nom avant qu'il ait trouvé son
emploi définitif
c'est une des manières que nous avons de
répondre ce problème des migrants voilà
alors eur 1 terminant s'arrêta père
barrette vos congrégation votre
congrégation en fait parce que la même
célèbre ses 150 ans bon est ce que il
faut parce que vous êtes là fait un
travail extraordinaire mais il va
falloir aussi garantir s'assurer que la
mission se poursuivre est-ce que du côté
de la relève
vous sentez que
les choses vont se poursuivre on parle
souvent de la crise dans le domaine de
la foi les gens qui sont de moins en
moins est de moins en moins dupes de
religieux est ce que vous êtes inquiet
pour la suite des choses bien vous êtes
plutôt optimiste à voir ce que certains
merci je dirais que je suis optimiste
la relève est beaucoup présentent en
afrique nous mêmes comme sur
missionnaire de notre dame d'afrique
nous avons accompagné de 25 ans deux
garçons qui sont très forts très
dynamique et nous avons eu nous mêmes
vingt-deux personnes en formation
initiale
donc avant les débuts d'un pas et nous
accueillent nous serions contents
d'accueillir d'autres de toutes
nationalités passons nous sommes
internationale oui c'est le même jour
chez nous on s'est toujours refusé à
prendre des africains parce que on
voulait d'abord donné au pays à l'église
locale
un personnel compétent maintenant que
cette oeuvre et 30 grande partie
réalisés soit qu'on aille ailleurs en
afrique soit comprennent on accepte des
jeunes qui désirent participer à nos vie
commune et à notre expérience de la
mission ailleurs que dans leur propre
pays
même ici au canada voilà sa régie
l'essai abrita tout temps et père gilles
barrette merci beaucoup d'être venus
dans nos studios